uh to play so as far as the game is
concerned i didn't change anything
just it was as a player i had to change
i trusted fonte
for that game or any other game i
trust fonte but i also trust all the
others that were
there with me and peppy and reuben
started that game
then semedo with diaz
uh uh i was already getting ready
also already ready to try cement to see
how it worked so it was more
like testing the
physical aspect of of these players in
the second
game there was no changes at all i mean
we are talking about the goal keeper
of course it's unfortunate that two of
our players
had to fall ill
this is never nice these are never
positive they both tested
positive to cove it now unfortunately we
have this
problem it's a this is an abnormal thing
of course as far as the game is
concerned
and i already said this a while ago
outside
any team that loses the best player in
the world cannot get better i mean
something would would be wrong if i said
so with the best player we would always
be better
but this team has already shown that we
have
the collective capacity to solve the
problems and i have absolute trust in my
players and what they can do tomorrow
so i'm tranquil of course i would like
to have
cristiano but if i don't i trust these
players and the the the those that's the
11 that start on the other side come in
will
certainly do a good job
now the covid issue is is is
sad is well in human terms for the
players for the men
but also because we have done
everything we are told we have taken
all precautions because health is
extremely important i can tell that
since
monday for for the past seven days we
are here
come find the staff
the players we arrived in here we were
all
tested and no one else has came in
it's like a bubble there's no one from
outside coming in or out
in the first training period where there
were no problems
these times there was a problem but not
because we broke the rules it just
happened
a player that tests positive in a on a
monday
uh um it wasn't here that he was
infected so the players
are very worried about abiding by
the safety rules now playing outside
that's normal but
anywhere that's how it works and here
after
seven after taking seven six or seven
tests as far as i'm as i i'm not
mistaken
so every day we have been tested and of
course
that leaves us with
a bitter flavor because we've done
everything right and this has happened
but it happens
and because no one knows yet exactly
how covid uh uh is transmitted i i'm not
a doctor i i i don't
have to understand it but what i
feel is that we do everything right we
play we take the buzz always together we
we
we never leave the hotel we go we come
back so everything we did we
followed we followed every um
health rules unfortunately this still
happened
that's life
now uh more questions from the
journalists that were sent
beforehand
another question that most journalists
asked is about how you have
lived the last hours in the national
team
uh how is the group reacting to
these news about ronaldo and how is
ronaldo himself
dealing with it well let me start with
that ronaldo is um
doing excellent he's living very well
with this
when he took this uh when he when he
took the new
test in the morning so he was in
isolation
last night after he took the test like
all of the players
they were went to the rooms then in the
morning
during during the night we knew about
him being infected
again we was tested in the morning and
the other players as well
cristiano immediately and isolated well
he has been in isolation since then he's
in his room
he says he wants to play he shouts to us
i want to play but he's doing well he's
doing is
asymptomatic he has no uh
problems he doesn't even know exactly
what happened to him
now as far as the first question is
concerned these were
three hard moments to us first fonte
we came here and the other day in the
morning
say we have a problem here a positive
case we have to test again
so for a moment we were uh
we were upset uh i can't say we are
happy about it of course we weren't
happy about it
we we were upset we were worried and
then we took another test and then that
happened again
with anthony uh lopez and now we don't
know though so
it's this is not something that is very
common
it's not common to happen and when
something that is uncommon
happens of course people comment
people's
people talk but as
things count down all the other players
took the tests
and fortunately ronaldo was still
positive all
others were negative okay
rock and roll it happened like this when
it happened
with france against the game against
sweden but pay was tested positive the
day after the game
he left and life went on and life goes
on here as well and we are happy
and we are ready to play tomorrow
from the swedish agency the impact of
the absence of christian ronald in your
game plan well in the game plan of
course
the dynamics will be different
but not the the whole strategy the
organization
i mean i would say that even the basic
dynamics offenses and defensive dynamics
they will be
very similar but cristiano has his
specific
particular characteristics and we know
everyone knows about that
and correctly
that with cristiano is a mobile player
that moves around from the left to the
middle on the middle to the right to the
left
and there has to be a certain
fluctuation uh between
among the the players up front to make
up for that so in those details
thing will be different but we have
played without cristiano before
and we did well and we maintained
our natural profile and that has to do
with the
uh dna of our players
a common er
made lately is that portugal is no fear
about
playing and looking eye in the eye of
the best
do you think that now the idea that we
can beat the best
has been uh strengthened uh i don't
think so i think that portugal
late in the last years and it's been
quite some years
has shown clearly and as air has always
been able to play
against any opponent we were in the
final of 2004 euro 2004
uh semifinals 2002 so we have been in
all
final stages in 2012 we were in the
semi-finals we lost
in the with spain uh in the penalty
shootout so
we have done excellent campaigns with
great capacity and quality
since i came here i i told you what i
believed in we i thought that portugal
would be a candidate
people thought i was crazy but i assumed
that portugal would be a candidate to
win the competition every game we play
we play to win
but we know that every game has its own
difficulties
some some difficulties others other
difficulties
playing against the world champion that
was the last game
and before one of the best teams in the
world
spain portugal did what we will always
do
we play the living that we can win
if we call it this playing uh ionize i
don't know
maybe not it's not always like that
because
the opponent we cannot always make this
happen
and sometimes the opponent does want not
to play iron
with us so portugal
is as proof and and i think this
shows how the other teams play against
us we are
respected and we and no one likes to
play against us
and just like there are things we would
like not to play against in quotes
because these are always the best games
of course but that's
you know what i'm trying to say but the
most important is that
the fundamental message is that portugal
now
is always ready to play these games and
we have to be
always prepared just like ruben said the
other games as well against teams like
sweden is
also a great team because the league of
nations
it's like the european championship some
years ago 16 teams four groups and only
one goes on to the next stage before it
there were two that went on to the next
stage so it's much more difficult in
such a scenario
meaning that all teams that are in this
first
league of uh league of nations are top
16
uh the uh um the stage that we go on
and the european chips that's after the
group stage but we are already in that
stage here
so this means that sweden is a
an excellent team great quality in
strategic terms and organization a team
that
works a lot and like nordic teams they
are very um they know
how to display their players on the
ground
they are very well organized defensively
they show
technical quality we often dispense
about dribbling
in terms of technical quality that's
what people see most but these
teams usually these plays are excellent
in terms of passing the ball and
receiving the ball
sweden other than these ingredients that
make it very
strong they have two excellent players
in the wings kokolevsky
that plays with ronaldo and forsberg
that
they also bring this additional
creativity imagination to the team so we
have to be very attentive because
the accounts in this group will pass by
sweden and we
cannot forget that well you already
answered several questions i had
to ask you here but from
tsf three very demanding
games in one week not many practices
there can always be some physical um
wearing out are you changing the team no
i'm not going to change
well i i have to change for the reasons
you know
so at least one challenge i'll have to
make i i didn't want to
we'll you'll see you'll see maybe one or
two other
changes but nothing it won't be very
different from the team that
played against france and if
the changes we may bring it's because of
the physical condition of the players
and this will be very demanding in
physical
terms so we know about that we are aware
of this
now from what happened
today stems this question
without ronaldo who will replace him
that i'm not going to tell you now
tomorrow you'll know you'll know
around 6 00 p.m you'll know who is going
to play
in ronaldo's place well
against france we had more of possession
of the bald and against spain
and maybe the change in the midfield
changed that
how are we going to play against sweden
the more defensive more offensive
team taking more risks well the
difference between the poor
the the france and spain game is that
in the first 25 minutes against spain we
our defensive offensive game we were
very far away from what is normal to us
and possession of the ball was more of
spain because our dna is possession of
the ball
but with objectivity and in the second
half in the game against spain that came
out very well
the team was better together
the game was more balanced we were able
to come
to have more possession with depth
understanding of the game
and always trying to create
opportunities to win because if you have
want to win you have to create
opportunities and we did have a few
chance
chances against spain in the game
against france
the question that was that problem that
we had against spain did not exist we we
were much better from the beginning
always well organized all times of the
game
namely when we did not have the ball and
when we lost the ball
we were able to recover quickly we were
not so well
in what we would expect after what
happened against
spain in the second half the offensive
actions we did attack but
we did not very as we should so
what i said is unlike what we had done
against croatia
and then last three games there were
able to be a
team that had the possession of the ball
sometimes short possession between
variation possession and death
against france we had more possession
of the ball but we did not we were not
so objective
about uh playing behind the backs of the
opponents but we did we did a a good
game
when i said this is it's not because i
think that we did not do a good game we
played
an excellent game but it was against the
world champion
and they also played with caution
against us so
this is a fruit of what our players did
on the
pitch but we had a very powerful
opponent i stress this and they didn't
allow us to do everything we wanted to
i think we could have done a little
better and because i want the best for
my team i want my players to do always
the best that's why i said what i did
what i said
you said that against france portugal
or you complain that porch will uh play
too much with the players always too
much close to each other
maybe with a jota trinkeon can be an
option
because they offer more variability
to the game well that was the reading in
that game in particular
if you go back to what i said after the
game against sweden or against croatia i
didn't say that
so in this particular game
in a few moments and
and those were important because the
wings of the french team
were at some problems and difficulties
and we we
could have done something that we did
well against croatia
against sweden this is the way we play
the players know
exactly what to do so there will be no
problems
jean felix said in the end of the game
against france that
they now they don't hear the the
supporters
uh tomorrow will be five thousand fans
in alvaladi would these be as
similar to the players or their home
factor without
uh the whether an audience will we
want to be an advantage well i'm not
saying that without an audience it's a
disadvantage with part of the
part of the advantage disappear of
course
5 000 fans that's that that's that's not
bad
in many championships in certain
fields in portugal 5 000 is is is a lot
but of course there were smaller stadia
it's always exciting to have an audience
five thousand ten thousand fifty
thousand it's always exciting
full stadium singing the national anthem
would be best
but with five thousand i think we'll be
we'll hear better
the people singing and that is very
important it's important to the players
we felt it today we fought it the other
day in france
when the national anthem was sung it was
the players that had to sing it
but it's important that this comes from
the outside it's important to me to the
players
in all aspects it's it's fundamental to
have an audience
to have the funds in the stadium uh with
what they have more than less
it's the end of this press conference
thank you again for
uh allowing us to have this distance
conference by sending your sending us
your questions thank you good afternoon
you